.
l'l'Association des médecins
mimicrobiologistes-infectiologus
dudu Québec,
J'J'entendais un spécialiste die
quque pourtant la deuxième dose
l'l'efficacité semblait tenir ps
mamal est-ce qu'on doit se
prprécipiter pas nécessairement,
popourquoi on recommande
auaujourd'hui cette troisième de
àà tous les adultes?
- - Il faut revenir à l'arrièreà
pepeu près tous les pays du mone
onont recommandé cette troisième
dodose. On sait que les États-
UnUnis, les Europ et les frères
onont vu les données depuis l'éé
dedernier sur l'importance de
cecette troisième dose les
prprovinces canadiennes embarqus
trtrès rapidement. La Colombie-
BrBritannique et l'Ontario ont
dédéjà leur plan pour vacciner s
plplus de 50 ans et les
trtravailleurs de la santé. Il y
a a que le Québec n'a pas encore
prpris de décision réelle et
rarapide à cet égard la. Pourqui
unune troisième dose d'âge on st
ququ'après six mois illuminés et
sesemble un peu diminuée et que
mmême si une certaine protection
ququi demeure contre la maladie
sésévère en comment savoir ce
ququ'on appelle des infections i
papassent à travers les maillesu
fifilet chez les travailleurs de
lala santé principalement même
s's'ils ne sont pas très malades
mamais ceux qui vont finir par
dodonner le virus aux personnes
hohospitalisées ou dans les CHS.
CeCes gens-là perdent leur
imimmunité avec le temps. Avoir
trtrois doses pour un, c'est pas
nonormal vous savait l'hépatite
dedes levées pH on donne souvent
trtrois doses pour avoir une
imimmunité à plus long terme et
leles données commencent à être
asassez clair pour montrer que a
trtroisième dose à cet effet de
memettre l'augmentation de
l'l'immunité et une protection
plplus long terme alors dans le
cocontexte où le nombre de cas
auaugmente au Québec même si on
sasait que c'est beaucoup ce chz
leles jeunes, même si on sait
ququ'il n'y a pas plus
d'd'hospitalisation, mais que ça
auaugmente rapidement et dans le
cocontexte dans la période des
ffêtes etc. on ne peut pas se
reretrouver au mois de janvier
avavec un autre à plus de cas ac
leles travailleurs de la santé
mamalade même s'ils ne sont pas
trtrès malades mais suffisamment
mamalades pour ne pas venir
trtravailler et on peut surtout
papas que les s patients déplurà
ririsque, des immuno compromis
totombe malade. On est arrivé là
avavec la pandémie.
- - Vous parlez des employés dea
sasanté mais est-ce que tout le
momonde même quelqu'un qui est
trtrès en santé qui a 45 ans ou0
anans devraient y aller quand ça
sesera?
- - Une fois qu'on a donné les
trtrois doses qu'on n'aura plus
bebesoin de vacciner les moins e
6060 en pleine santé?
EsEst-ce qu'on va devoir vaccinr
leles plus de 80 ans une fois en
dedeux ans on ne le sait pas
enencore. Mais les trois doses
vovous le savez à la naissance s
bébébés on les vaccine aux deux
momois aux quatre mois donc
l'l'aspect de donner des dose en
SySyrie de trois ce n'est pas
nonouveau pour le système
imimmunitaire. Au long terme sot
veveut avoir une efficacité c'et
cece que la troisième dose
sesemblait faire ici ce que la
lilittérature semble démontrer
prprésentement. Je pense que
l'l'idée c'est de protéger le ps
dede monde possible. Il y a des
ququestions qu'on ne connaît pas
enencore sur la durée de la
prprotection etc. mais je pense
quque globalement on est rendu à
etet c'est ce qui fait dans tous
leles autres pays.
- - Et justement j'allais entrer
leles variants là-dedans le
nonouveau variant Omicron, on a
didit que c'est même pas en
fofonction du nouveau variant
ququ'on recommande cela il n'y a
quque le delta qu'on ne le
rerecommanderait également.
- - Oui le delta pour l'instant
c'c'est le plus important. Pour
leles autres et qui ont vacciné
plplutôt que nous aider dose pls
rarapprochée liée espace idéal
enentre deux doses on sait
auaujourd'hui que c'est entre ht
etet six semaines, mais on sait
quque même pour le delta ça a un
efeffet positif. Pour les variat
OmOmicron même si les données st
trtrès préliminaires et limitées
ilil semble que les variants
OmOmicron les gens qui sont
dodoublement vaccinés sont
prprotégés contre une maladie
sésévère donc même s'il est
popositif ils ne vont pas
dédévelopper une maladie sévère.
DiDisons que c'est déjà
enencourageant.
- - On a déjà utilisé des
ananalogies guerrières je vous
momontre de graphiques. Le nombe
de c cas en deux semaines on a
fafait une courbe sur deux
sesemaines, le nombre de cas
auaugmente au Québec.
MaMais le nombre
d'd'hospitalisations entiers le
cocoup ça augmente légèrement. s
hohospitalisations voilà vous ls
vovoyer. C'est une bonne nouvele
çaça?
- - Si une combinaison de la
cacampagne de vaccination qui
momontre l'effet protecteur sur
unune grande majeure et de la
popopulation surtout les plus
vuvulnérables, il faut montrer e
c'c'est d'autant plus remarquabe
onon a ouvert la société. En fat
bebeaucoup plus de choses, les
gegens sont retournés à l'école,
onon va au cinéma, on va au
rerestaurant, on va au Centre Bl
enen début de l'ouverture de la
sosociété dans un certain pointn
a a quand même un nombre de cas
ququi a augmenté, mais un nombre
d'd'hospitalisations qui n'ont s
tetellement augmenté et qui rese
ququand même le gérable. Ce qu'n
pepeut penser que le nombre
auaugmente et la période des fês
popourrait les multiplier. C'est
unun virus qui aime bien l'hiver
dodonc on ne peut pas se retrour
avavec une augmentation importae
auau mois de janvier. Mais, il
fafaut savoir que c'est un
enensemble de mesures qui misent
enensemble font en sorte qu'on
pepeut tenir la route en assez
adadéquatement. Il n'y a rien de
ababsolu et ce n'est pas 100 %
efefficaces et masqués la
vavaccination donc la
didistanciation un rôle à jouer.
CoComme toutes les barrières
enensemble on arrive à maintenir
unune situation satisfaisante à
l'l'échelle sociétale pour qu'on
pupuisse faire fonctionner de
fafaçon normale. Il y a personne
ququi peut donnener un confinemt
etet être isolé. C'est la façone
gagarder la société ouverte.
- - En terminant, on ne pourra s
fafaire l'économie d'une
vavaccination internationale les
chchiffres en Afrique, les, les
chchiffres en Amérique du Sud st
trtrès bas même en Haïti ces 2 %
lele taux de vaccination ici ces
8282 % à peu près au Canada. Es-
cece que vous imaginez un
scénénario?
OuOù ces pays-là ne seraient
jajamais vaccinés?
- - Je pense que dans un premier
tetemps il faut savoir que la
prproduction des vaccins à
l'l'échelle planétaire a été
susuffisante pour vacciner toute
momonde. Il y a quand même des
efefforts sont faits dans certas
papays pour permettre aux pays
plplus pauvres d'avoir accès à s
vavacciner la. Il y a dans
cecertains cas je vous dirais ds
prproblèmes d'accès logistique
dadans certains endroits il y a
auaussi des fois un certain refs
àà être vacciné dans certains
enendroits, comme en Occident,
cocomme dans certains pays des
IlIl y a des portes mais il y a
auaussi des Honderich dans les
papays pauvres et vous avez ausi
dedes zones sont beaucoup plus
vavaccinés. Il faut aussi remete
leles choses en perspective mais
c'c'est très important d'essayer
dede vacciner tout le monde sura
plplanète le plus possible toutn
sasachant que ce virus va
prprobablement passer d'une
papandémie à une endémie c'est--
didire de vivre avec avec un
cecertain bruit de fond mais avc
lelequel on va s'incommoder dans
leles packs sera limité. Il va y
avavoir des réservoirs animaux
enenvoyés que des cervidés sont
atatteints et des félins aussi
mmême s'ils ne sont pas très
mamalades ça veut dire que même
sasans vacciner toute la planète
etet qu'on protégeait tout le
momonde, le vaccin ne peut jamas
êêtre 100 % protecteurs, il va
totoujours rester des coronavirs
ququelque part sur la planète cz
leles animaux. Il pourrait rever
dadans l'espèce humaine à moment
dodonné. Ça veut dire qu'il faut
ququ'on ait un vaccin qui protèe
cocontre la maladie c'est pardon
sisi on se retrouve avec un pett
rhrhume de temps en temps ce n't
papas si grave mais que ça prote
lele système hospitalier. Et çaa
nonous permettre de retourner à
unune vie normale et sur une
peperspective historique ça va
reressembler à l'influenza russe
dede 1989 qui étaient le C 43 qi
esest devenu un simple rhume avc
leles années et les décennies dc
sisi l'évolution de ce virus.
- - Souhaitons le.
- - Et les Omicron montent c'est
pepeut-être moins sévère donc on
pepeut faire des scénarios, mais
onon est en train de passer